I meant to play this earlier in the week
and I wasn't able to get to it and I
don't want to skip over it because it is
so strange and interesting Donald Trump
put out a statement about how he helped
the farmers avoid an estate tax but in
the discussion of it he talks about how
if you don't love your kids you don't
have to leave them your farm and it has
a very weird undertone where many people
saw this and speculated and wrote To Me
is This Trump signaling he doesn't love
his kids and he's not leaving them his
an inheritance it is very strange I want
you to take a look at this and tell me
what you think and I made farmers happy
and Rich again
and they're doing a fantastic job
and you know what
someday it'll become time for them to
leave this beautiful Earth
and they'll be able to leave their Farm
without taxes all right okay so far I
understand the policy to their children
I got rid of the death tax on farms
so that when you do pass away
on the assumption that you love your
children
you can leave it to them and they won't
have to pay tax
but if you don't love your children so
much and there are some people that
don't and maybe deservedly so it won't
matter because frankly you don't have to
leave them anything thank you very much
have fun have fun with that guys huh our
friend Aaron rupar on Twitter said that
he had to watch this two times merely to
convince himself that it wasn't some
kind of deep fake AI prank because it's
so bizarre so a couple different things
here first of all it sort of seems like
this is being written into Trump's
scripts because he said something very
similar on March 13th in Iowa and he
said it in an almost identical way and
then of course the bigger question that
many of you are wondering about is is
this Donald Trump signaling something to
his own children is this Donald Trump
signaling that that maybe it is he who
doesn't love his kids it's absolutely
bizarre and strange and the focus now
multiple times on people who don't love
their kids really strange stuff
I don't know what to make of it let me
know in the comments what you think good
habits have to be sustainable something
you'll actually stick to I start my
mornings with a scoop of ag1 by our
sponsor athletic greens because it's
just so simple one scoop of ag1 gives me
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals from Whole
Foods sources half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A C and magnesium
taking that scoop of ag1 makes sure that
I'm getting the nutrients I want without
fumbling with different capsules and
dosages and all of these things ag1 is
also way more cost effective than buying
all of those different vitamins I drink
ag1 straight with water because I like
the taste but you could put it in a
smoothie a juice a protein shake I would
not promote
supplements making crazy claims there's
no crazy claims here ag1 is just a
simple product it does what it says it
does it helps me get what I want to get
every day and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you will get a
free year supply of vitamin D plus five
free travel packs of ag1 I've talked
about vitamin D before the link is down
below